have you ever heard of Medusa the
snake-haired Greek monster who turns
people to stone with a single glance
well she may just be a myth but there is
an area so deadly that it could actually
turn you to stone the infamous Lake
Natron what makes Lake Natron water so
dangerous what kind of creatures live
there and could you survive if you fell
in this is what in and here's what would
happen if you jumped into Lake Natron
before we take the plunge we'd better
look at what Lake Natron is made of much
like the Dead Sea this Tanzanian Lake
doesn't run off into any oceans or
rivers this allows it to soak up all
that salty desert rain soupy yet what
makes it especially lethal is its close
proximity to the active volcano owes
Doinyo Lengai the volcano spews a rare
kind of lava rich in sodium and
potassium carbonate called natural
carbonatite or Natron for short
releasing into the water this mix of
sodium carbonate and sodium bicarbonate
were key ingredients once used in
Egyptian mummification creating the
perfect preservative in Lake form
the whole chemical composition is
extremely alkaline with pH levels of
10.5 close to that of ammonia
this gives the lake its rosy hue any
birds who happen to take a dive and
don't make it out become calcified in a
hardened stone like husk talk about
killing two birds with one stone
in 2013 wildlife photographer Nick
Brandt was one of the first to document
this phenomenon he discovered several
stone birds and other unlucky animals in
the dry season when the water had
receded he theorized that since the lake
is so mirror-like and reflective the
birds must have flown right into it as
if it was a big glass door but despite
so many birds dying in Lake Natron there
is a particular species flourishing
turns out the lakes toxic waters provide
a safe haven from predators making it
perfect flamingos flocking grounds so if
flamingos can handle it couldn't we well
it's not that simple unfortunately
flamingos thrive in salty lakes because
of their tough skin and scaly legs which
prevent birds they can drink the fresh
water from nearby Springs or geysers at
the edges of the lake and if they're
desperate enough they can even filter
saltwater with special glands in their
nasal cavities and to top it all off
their strong stomachs allow them to feed
on the toxic algae found throughout the
lake
this makes Lake Natron the perfect spot
to raise and protect their young so
let's say we've tried to live like a
flamingo and decided to take a dip well
depending on the time of year the water
can be a
sixty degrees which is hot enough to
cause third-degree burns and five
seconds or less also I wouldn't plan on
doing any fancy dives or cannonballs as
it's shallowness is also chock full of
sharp salty structures you wouldn't be
turned to stone instantly but if you
happen to drown and stay submerged your
entire body would Harden and be
preserved if people found you hundreds
of years later you might still have your
hair and organs intact ya still lookin
spiffy after all those years like
mummification natron's super high
alkalinity stops the decomposition
process thankfully this means you'd be
safe from vultures or any other hungry
scavengers looking for a snack if you
waited into the lake at a time when the
water temperature was lower it could
feel more like a hot tub but your eyes
or any open wounds would sting like
crazy because of all that salt I'd strap
on some goggles if I were you in 2007
another bird flew straight into this
chemical cocktail a group of wildlife
videographers plunged into Lake Natron
toxicity when their helicopter crashed
the pilot suffered a broken leg and
another passenger had a broken hip
incredibly one of the passengers managed
to struggle to shore and alerted some of
the Masai tribes people nearby they
quickly built stretchers and carried the
injured to land in the nick of time
even though you could survive Lake
Natron swatters I'd stick to a swimming
pool if I were you as for our flamingo
friends this just goes to show how the
harshest environments can be a sanctuary
for some animals but if you're craving
something even more extreme
how about surviving a limnic eruptions
on your next swim think you could handle
it
be sure to check out our new series how
to survive to find out more
you